From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Jacobs and the other guys did not like their boss, Manright. Manright was full of himself, he took credit for things that they did, he was hard to deal with. And they set out to sabotage him. A sociologist named Calvin Morrill, watched how they did it as part of a study of office politics in different companies. These guys all worked for an old line banking firm that he calls Old Financial. All the names in this story have been changed.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。雅各布和其他人不喜欢他们的老板曼赖特。曼赖特自以为是，把别人的功劳据为己有，很难相处。于是他们开始密谋破坏他的工作。一位名叫卡尔文·莫里尔的社会学家在对不同公司的办公室政治进行研究时，观察了他们的做法。这些人都在一家他称之为“老金融”的老牌银行公司工作。故事中的所有名字都已更改。
In traditional companies like this one, Morrill says, all the politics happen in secret. It's all subterfuge. Here is how Manright was destroyed by Jacobs.
莫里尔说，在像这样的传统公司里，所有的政治斗争都在秘密进行。全是瞒天过海的诡计。这就是雅各布如何搞垮曼赖特的经过。
Manright used to rely on this fellow, Jacobs, to prepare him before he would go before the senior executive committee meeting. And Jacobs is very good, very smart guy. And he could anticipate some of the questions that his boss would be asked at these meetings. And so when he prepped him, he would just neglect to tell his boss about some of the key questions that he could anticipate being asked. And there his boss would stand at the committee meeting, naked, without the information that he needed. And eventually, he was removed as a result of this.
曼赖特过去常依赖雅各布在高级执行委员会会议前为他做准备。雅各布是个非常出色、非常聪明的人。他能预见到老板在这些会议上会被问到的一些问题。所以，当他为老板准备时，他会故意隐瞒一些他预见到的关键问题。结果，当老板在委员会会议上发言时，就像赤身裸体一样，没有他所需的信息。最终，他因此被撤职了。
Now did Manright understand that he had been sabotaged?
那么，曼赖特意识到自己被破坏了吗？
He didn't. Actually, he got back each time-- this happened to him over the course of several meetings, where he was mis-prepped, if you will-- and each time he came back, he was firmly convinced that his subordinates were incompetent, because how else could this have happened? It never dawned on him that they were so competent that they might actually be intentionally engaged in sabotage.
他没有。事实上，他每次都回来了——这发生在他参加的几次会议期间，每次都被“误导”了——每次回来，他都坚信下属们很无能，因为不然怎么会发生这种事呢？他从未想到他们竟能干练到这种程度，以至于可能在故意搞破坏。
Another multibillion dollar company that Morrill studied is one that he calls Playco, in the toy and education product business. Unlike Old Financial-- where bosses were bosses and underlings were underlings, and so all the scheming had to go on in secret-- at Playco, there was no real hierarchy. It wasn't clear who was in charge of whom. And while that might sound like a kind of nice place to work, with no big bosses, it turns out that with no one absolutely in charge to make decisions and keep people in line, all the fighting was right out in the open. At meetings, people would try to humiliate and out argue each other. They would form alliances. The executives at Playco would talk all the time about honor and respect, as if they were medieval knights, or maybe mob figures.
莫里尔研究的另一家数十亿美元的公司，他称之为“Playco”，从事玩具和教育产品业务。与“老金融”不同——那里老板就是老板，下属就是下属，所以所有的勾心斗角都必须秘密进行——在Playco，没有真正的等级制度。谁管谁并不明确。虽然听起来这可能是一个不错的工作环境，没有大老板，但事实证明，由于没有绝对负责的人来做决定和约束员工，所有的争斗都是公开进行的。在会议上，人们会试图羞辱对方，在争论中压倒对方。他们会结成联盟。Playco的高管们总是谈论荣誉和尊重，就好像他们是中世纪的骑士，或者黑帮人物。
Then I even witnessed violence in this firm between executives. One of the incidents I talk about was about two executives actually getting into a fistfight in front of the world headquarters of this multinational firm.
甚至我还在这家公司目睹过高管之间的暴力事件。我提到的其中一个事件是两位高管在这家跨国公司的全球总部前发生了拳脚冲突。
Yeah, just tell what happened between those two.
好吧，请讲讲那两个人之间发生了什么。
Yeah, well one guy was called-- I call him Greer. And the other guy actually had a nickname, called the Terminator. And he was called the Terminator because, as this one guy said, he liked to hunt big game. He liked to look for executives who he could best in arguments at meetings. And so these guys were parking their cars in the parking lot. And they called each other out, essentially.
嗯，其中一个叫——我称他为格里尔。另一个人其实有个绰号，叫“终结者”。他被称为“终结者”是因为，正如某人所说，他喜欢猎捕“大猎物”。他喜欢寻找那些他在会议争论中可以胜过的高管。于是，这两个人在停车场停车时，基本上是相互挑衅了对方。
Greer accused the Terminator of playing around with women at a local health club and embarrassing the corporation. Meanwhile, the Terminator accused Greer of being a weak executive. This thing escalated. And after a few minutes, one of them had the other over his Lotus sports car.
格里尔指责“终结者”在当地的一家健身俱乐部里和女人们鬼混，让公司蒙羞。与此同时，“终结者”指责格里尔是个软弱的高管。事情升级了。几分钟后，其中一个人把另一个人压在了他的莲花跑车上。
There is this idea in capitalism that companies are making decisions, and products, and strategy, based on rational evaluation of the market and their customers. To what degree is that true, based on what you saw? And to what degree are decisions being made based on office politics, and not a rational evaluation of where their company is in the market?
资本主义中有一种观点认为，公司是基于对市场和客户的理性评估来做出决定、产品和战略的。根据你的观察，这种观点在多大程度上是真实的？而决策在多大程度上是基于办公室政治，而不是基于公司在市场中所处位置的理性评估？
There is some rationality. But thinking about the bottom line is sometimes a myth that outsiders tell each other about how decisions are made. And it's not always about the bottom line. It's about politics with one another, maneuvering with one another.
确实存在一定的理性。但关注底线有时是局外人对决策方式的一种迷思。这并不总是关于底线。而是关于彼此之间的政治博弈和操纵。
Given all that, given all the conflict that Calvin Morrill saw at all kinds of offices, what is surprising is not how many fistfights there are in offices, but how few. I know I've been in one. This happened years ago on a public radio show that was just starting up. And I do not think of myself as much of a fighter. But here's how it went down. The guy who raised the money to start this show had this vision. And what his vision was, was he said, what if there were a radio show where you could turn on every day, and you would hear something like Spike Lee, and Philip Glass, the composer, and Stephen Hawking, the physicist, sitting down together, and just talking, talking about the things that interest them in common.
鉴于卡尔文·莫里尔在各种办公室看到的所有冲突，令人惊讶的不是办公室里有多少次拳脚冲突，而是竟然这么少。我知道我曾卷入过一次。那是几年前在一个刚开播的公共广播节目中。我不认为自己是一个好斗的人。但事情是这样的。那个筹钱创办这个节目的人有一个愿景。他的愿景是，他说，如果有一个广播节目，你每天打开都能听到像斯派克·李、作曲家菲利普·格拉斯和物理学家斯蒂芬·霍金这样的人坐在一起，谈论他们共同感兴趣的事情，那会怎样？
So this show was two hours a day. This guy had never worked on a daily program. He had done other stuff, but never a daily program. I and a number of the other people who worked on the show had worked on daily shows. At the time, by the way, I was not on the air. I was just a producer.
所以这个节目每天两小时。这个家伙从未从事过每日节目。他做过其他事情，但从没做过每日节目。我和其他几个在节目组工作的人都做过每日节目。顺便说一句，当时我没在直播，我只是个制作人。
And so we're trying to start this show. And every day, we would come in, and we would work, and work, and work, and work. And every day we would have this experience of-- we would say, OK, here is  what we think we can do. It was a very, very small staff. Very small staff. And every day we would say, OK, here is what we think we can do this week. And we would lay out the programs, and this, and this, and this, and this. And at the end of the whole thing-- all this work had gone into it-- at the end of the whole thing, the guy who had raised all the money and was our boss would say, you know, that's really very nice. But it's just not our original idea. It's not Spike Lee, and Philip Glass, and Stephen Hawking sitting down and talking to each other.
于是我们努力开办这个节目。每天我们进去，工作，工作，工作，工作。每天我们都会有这样的经历——我们会说，好吧，这是我们认为我们可以做的。员工非常非常少。非常少的员工。每天我们都会说，好吧，这是我们认为本周可以做的。我们会列出节目，这个，这个，这个，这个。在所有这些工作完成后——所有这些努力都投入进去了——最后，那个筹集了所有资金并担任我们老板的人会说，你知道，这真的很好。但这不是我们最初的想法。这不是斯派克·李、菲利普·格拉斯和斯蒂芬·霍金坐在一起交谈。
And those of us who had worked on daily programs would always say to him, you know, that is a perfectly good idea. That is a very valid idea. A perfectly good idea. But you have to remember that you are on for two hours a day. You have two people making phone calls and booking this, you have one or two tape cutters, one or two other people. It was a very, very small staff. And so even if you could get Spike Lee, and Philip Glass, and Stephen Hawking into a room, and you could figure out what in the world they actually have to say to each other, which would take a certain amount of research and time on someone's part, even if you could make all this happen, that's only one hour. That's only going to be one show. And so we have to think about what's going to happen in all these other hours. And so that's a very good idea, a very fine idea. But here are all these other ideas that we're going to do to fill all this other time too.
而我们这些做过每日节目的人总是对他说，你知道，那是个很好的主意。那是一个非常有效的想法。一个非常好的主意。但你必须记住你每天要播出两个小时。你只有两个人负责打电话和预订嘉宾，有一两个剪辑师，一两个其他人。员工真的非常非常少。所以即使你能把斯派克·李、菲利普·格拉斯和斯蒂芬·霍金请到一个房间里，即使你能弄清楚他们到底能聊些什么，而这需要一定的研究和时间，即使你能让这一切发生，那也只有一个小时。那只能是一期节目。所以我们必须考虑其他时间该播什么。所以这是一个很好的主意，一个非常好的想法。但这里还有其他所有我们要做来填补剩下时间的主意。
And this went on for day after day and week after week. And people were working very, very hard and sort of burning out. And finally, after weeks of this, we're all standing around. And we've just finished our first five shows. And it has been grueling. It has been really, really hard. And we're evaluating what to do next, and how we should change the format of the show, and all that kind of thing. And we get to the end of this long, long discussion. And it seems like we're all on the same page. And at last, we're all in accord. Here is where we've been, here is where we're going.
这种情况持续了好多天，好几周。人们工作非常非常努力，都有点精疲力竭了。终于，几周后，我们都站在那里。我们刚刚完成了前五期节目。这真是令人筋疲力尽。真的，真的很难。我们正在评估下一步该做什么，以及我们应该如何改变节目的形式，诸如此类的事情。我们进行了长时间的讨论。看起来我们都达成了一致。终于，我们达成了一致。我们从哪里来，我们要去哪里。
And our boss says, well, you know, there's one thing that we haven't gotten to. And that is, I think we're forgetting the original idea of the show, that really what it needs to be is-- I think every hour needs to be more like-- well, just imagine if Spike Lee, and Philip Glass, and Stephen Hawking could sit down together and just chat about whatever.
我们的老板说，嗯，你知道，有一件事我们还没提到。那就是，我想我们忘记了节目最初的想法，真正需要的是——我想每一小时都需要更像——嗯，想象一下如果斯派克·李、菲利普·格拉斯和斯蒂芬·霍金能坐在一起随便聊聊。
And it had been a really hard few weeks. And as Nelson Mandela said in a very different context, you know, we had tried reason, but reason had failed to produce a solution. And so violence was our only option. And I didn't really see anything else to do. Well, to say I didn't see anything implies a kind of thinking that really wasn't exactly happening. It was just straight, pretty much gut instinct. And I walked over, and I punched him in the stomach.
那真是艰难的几周。正如纳尔逊·曼德拉在完全不同的语境中所说，你知道，我们尝试了理性，但理性未能拿出解决方案。所以暴力成了我们唯一的选择。我真的没看到别的办法。嗯，说我没看到任何东西意味着某种思考过程，而这并不完全是当时的情况。这只是直觉，纯粹的直觉。我走过去，给了他一拳。
And his reaction, I have to say, was not really as satisfying as I was hoping for. He was sort of cushiony. I didn't feel like I was making much of an impression. And we're standing very, very close now, closer, I think, than we had ever stood to each other. And he looks me in the eyes. And he's a little bit sweaty. And he doesn't get mad at all. The whole thing just makes him get really, really sincere.
不得不说，他的反应并不是我希望的那样。他有点肉乎乎的。我觉得没对他造成什么影响。我们现在站得非常非常近，我想比我们以往任何时候站得都要近。他看着我的眼睛。他出了一点汗。他根本没有生气。这一切反而让他变得非常、非常真诚。
And he says, "You know, Ira, I really think that you should think about what you're doing for a second." Which I have to say, just made me madder. Like if you're really mad at somebody, and they just start to talk to you like they're your therapist, it just makes you madder. And so I punched him again. And again, not terribly satisfying and sort of a cushiony kind of feeling. And punches don't make as much of a sound in real life as you think they might.
他说，“你知道，艾拉，我真的认为你应该好好想想你在做什么。”不得不说，这让我更生气了。就像如果你真的很生某人的气，而他们开始像治疗师一样跟你说话，那只会让你更生气。所以我又给了他一拳。同样，效果不怎么让人满意，感觉有点肉乎乎的。而且现实中拳头打人并没有你想象中那么响。
And again, he sort of looks me-- our faces very close to each other-- looks me in the eye, and he says, "You know, Ira, I think you're really having some feelings here that maybe you might be expressing a different way." Which of course, made me punch him again.
他再次看着我——我们的脸靠得很近——看着我的眼睛，他说，“你知道，艾拉，我认为你现在真的有一些情绪，也许你可以用另一种方式表达出来。”这当然让我又给了他一拳。
At this point, at the third punch, pretty much people had gathered around us. And I was pulled off by the public radio staff of the show, which included a guy in a wheelchair, which gives you a sense of the tough kind of fight that was going on here. And I say all
this now just to illustrate that even in the offices of an outfit known for its calm-voiced, let us all sit down together and reason together kind of reasonableness, even in the offices of public radio, even here, in the office where I speak to you from right now, feelings are so extreme that they can lead to hitting. Our relationships at our jobs, I think, contain all of the feelings we have in all of our personal relationships. There are people you like, people you don't like. There is gratitude, there is resentment, there is jealousy. It's all there. All the feelings are there. Except in the workplace we can't express it, because it's a workplace. You have to keep it bottled up inside, and then it ends up seeping out in all these other ways.
此时，在第三拳时，周围已经围满了人。我被节目的公共广播工作人员拉开了，其中还包括一个坐轮椅的家伙，这让你能感觉到当时那场架打得有多激烈。我现在说这些只是为了说明，即使在以声音平和、大家坐下来理性沟通而闻名的机构办公室里，即使在公共广播的办公室里，即使就在我现在跟你说话的这个办公室里，情绪也是如此极端，以至于会导致动手。我认为，我们在工作中的人际关系包含了我们在个人生活中所有的感受。有你喜欢的人，有你不喜欢的人。有感激，有怨恨，有嫉妒。全都在那里。所有的感受都在那里。只是在工作场所我们不能表达出来，因为那是工作场所。你必须把它憋在心里，然后它最终会以各种其他方式渗漏出来。
Well, today on our program, Office Politics, we bring you three stories of conflict and high drama from our nation's workplaces. Act One, Hang in There Kitty Cat, It's Almost Friday. In that act, a lowly office worker gets in a jam, and discovers that in times of trouble, when all else has failed, when all hope is gone, companies in her industry turn to one woman, one woman, my friend, in a suburban home in Long Island, who solves their corporate problems without ever turning off the TV that plays in the background.
好了，今天在我们的节目《办公室政治》中，我们将为您带来三个来自我们国家职场中关于冲突和高强度戏剧性的故事。第一幕，“挺住，小猫，快到周五了”。在那一幕中，一个卑微的办公室职员陷入了困境，并发现当麻烦来临时，当一切都失败了，当所有的希望都破灭了，她所在行业的公司会求助于一个女人，一个女人，我的朋友，在一个长岛的郊区房子里，她在不关闭背景里播放的电视的情况下，解决了他们的公司难题。
Act Two, Sheetcakes in the Conference Room, Whiskey After Dark. David Rakoff discusses the world of birthdays and other holidays, as they are celebrated on the job.
第二幕，“会议室里的纸蛋糕，深夜的威士忌”。大卫·拉科夫讨论了工作场所庆祝生日和其他节日的现状。
Act Three, When the Job to Get You off the Streets Is on the Streets. In that act we hear stories of the intricate office politics that take place in a location where you might not suspect there is any politics because there is no office. Stay with us.
第三幕，“当为了让你远离街头的职业就在街头上时”。在那一幕中，我们听到了一些错综复杂的办公室政治故事，这些故事发生在一个你可能根本想不到会有政治的地方，因为那里根本就没有办公室。请继续收听。
Act One, Hang in There Kitty Cat, It's Almost Friday. Starlee Kine tells the tale in this act of an office problem that refused to be solved by ordinary means, and so extraordinary means had to be employed.
第一幕，“挺住，小猫，快到周五了”。斯塔莉·凯恩讲述了一个无法通过常规手段解决的办公室问题，因此必须采用非常手段。
Kelly worked for small start up. There were only about a dozen people on the staff. And the office was just one big room with no walls, like in a classroom. And a lot of the same office politics that happens behind closed doors in other offices happened in this one, except without the doors.
凯利为一家小型初创公司工作。员工只有十几个人。办公室是一个没有墙的大房间，就像教室一样。其他办公室里发生在门后的许多办公室政治，在这个办公室里也发生了，只是没有门。
It didn't take long before the employees took on the established roles. There was a cool kid, the flirt, the gossip, the nice boss who was really mean, the mean boss who was really nice. There was even the person who functioned as the unofficial psychologist. Every office has one, the person who is everyone's confidant, who listens to your problems and gives you a shoulder to cry on. In this office, though, the politics were so extreme that even she couldn't be trusted.
没过多久，员工们就担任了既定的角色。有酷孩子，调情的人，爱嚼舌根的人，表面友善其实很刻薄的老板，表面刻薄其实很友善的老板。甚至还有担任非官方心理学家的人。每个办公室都有一个，那个成为每个人知己的人，倾听你的问题，给你肩膀依靠。但在在这个办公室里，政治气氛太极端了，甚至她都不可信。
Our person would come in with the person who was crying. And the person who was crying would be like, "Thanks. I'll buy you a beer sometime. I really needed to get that off my chest." And the psychologist would be like, "It's OK, anytime. I'll be right back." And literally walk over to the person, who the other person had just been saying is torturing them, making their life hell, and that they think might want to kill them, and then go over and be like, "You see that person sitting right there? Yeah. The one right in front of you? She thinks that you might want to kill her."
我们会带着哭泣的人进来。哭泣的人会说，“谢谢。改天请你喝啤酒。我真的很需要把它说出来。”而那个“心理学家”会说，“没关系，随时都可以。我马上回来。”然后径直走向那个人刚刚说在折磨她、让生活变得像地狱、她认为可能想杀了她的人，然后走过去说，“你看到坐在那里的那个人了吗？对，就在你面前的那个？她认为你可能想杀了她。”
Since it was a start up, the company was having trouble even staying in business. Pressure was high, hours were long. There was lots of stress, and breakdowns, and tears, and fighting, and of course, sex.
因为是初创公司，公司甚至难以维持经营。压力很大，工时很长。有很多压力、崩溃、泪水、争吵，当然，还有性。
There was one person, in particular, who was sleeping with one of the women in the office. And until the last day, I think that most of the staff thought he was gay. There was a woman who was heterosexual, but obviously had a crush on the one lesbian we had in the office, like a hot and heavy crush. And also on the men, too. She doesn't discriminate. And a certain amount of sexual tension is great. It gets you to get up in the morning, to actually wash your hair. But in this office it was flying at you from such strange directions. And there were couplings happening within office.
其中一个人特别地和办公室里的一个女人睡在一起。直到最后一天，我想大多数员工还以为他是同性恋。有一个异性恋女人，但显然暗恋办公室里唯一的那个女同性恋者，就像那种火辣辣的暗恋。也对男人们也一样。她不挑食。适度的性张力很棒。它让你早上起床，真正去洗头。但在办公室里，它从如此奇怪的方向向你飞来。而且办公室里确实发生了耦合。
From Kelly's perspective, the creepiest coupling was between her two bosses. The three of them were working super closely on a new project. The two bosses had both pretty much already hated her, and it had been hard enough to deal with them as individuals. But together they formed this sort of invincible two-headed monster of hate. And Kelly was their number one target.
从凯利的视角来看，最令人毛骨悚然的耦合是发生在她两个老板之间。他们三个人在一个新项目上合作得非常紧密。两个老板基本上都已经恨她了，把他们当作独立的个人来对付已经够难的了。但他们在一起形成了一种无敌的、双头的仇恨怪兽。而凯利是他们的头号目标。
When you're working with a very small staff, it's like being stuck on a ship with people. That's your only existence at all. So let's say you're stuck on this boat. You're out at sea, calm waters in the beginning, a lot of celebrating, I like you, do you like me? I like you too. Yeah! And then things start to get rougher. Things start to get rougher. People are testy, because they've been stuck in that boat for a long time. You now know things, things that you don't even want to know about people. You're forced to know in those environments. So imagine that. And then imagine the two people that I need to work with on a daily basis not talking to me, and not liking me, and sleeping together.
当你和很少的员工一起工作时，就像被困在一艘船上的人们。那是你全部的存在。所以假设你被困在这条船上。你在海上，起初风平浪静，大家都在庆祝，我喜欢你，你喜欢我吗？我也喜欢你。耶！然后情况开始变得艰难。情况开始变得艰难。人们很暴躁，因为他们被困在船上很长时间了。你现在知道了些事情，一些你甚至不想知道的关于人们的事情。在这种环境下你被迫去知道。所以想象一下。然后想象我每天需要合作的两个人不跟我说话，不喜欢我，并且睡在一起。
So imagine we're all on that boat. And we have to make room for them to sleep with each other. We're like, OK, move over on the cots.
所以想象我们都在那条船上。我们必须腾出空间让他们睡觉。我们说，好吧，在行军床上让让位。
They just wouldn't make eye contact with me, wouldn't talk to me for the entire deadline that we were on. And also this person is only sitting six feet away from me. So the uncomfortability of that was through the roof.
他们根本不跟我有眼神交流，在我们工作的整个截止日期内也不跟我说话。而且这个人离我只有六英尺远。所以那种不适感简直冲破了天际。
And then, slowly the ship began to sink. They were running out of money. The bosses grew paranoid, and started picking off their employees one by one. A person answered the phone incorrectly, and was fired that same day.
然后，船慢慢开始沉了。他们没钱了。老板们变得多疑，开始一个接一个地裁掉员工。某人接电话没接好，当天就被解雇了。
Malaise set in. Employees started coming in late or not at all. No one believed in the project anymore. And then one day, some irreplaceable photographs that Kelly was in charge of went missing.
萎靡不振开始蔓延。员工开始迟到或根本不来。没人再相信这个项目了。然后有一天，凯利负责保管的一些不可替代的照片不见了。
I looked everywhere. I looked in the bookcases, under my desk. I looked in other people's offices on our floor. I looked in the drawers that were public. We had public drawers where people could store stuff. And then we had drawers that were private, which I didn't go into when people were there. But I did get so desperate that I went through everyone's stuff. I was getting irrational.
我到处找。我在书柜里找，在我的桌子底下找。我在我们楼层其他人的办公室里找。我在公共抽屉里找。我们有人们可以存放东西的公共抽屉。然后我们有私人抽屉，我没在人们在的时候进去。但我确实绝望到翻了所有人的东西。我变得不理智了。
Kelly suspected that one of her bosses had stolen the photographs. They knew that she had to return the photos to the photographer, and that her reputation was on the line. It would be a huge embarrassment if she had to actually call the photographer and tell him they were gone. In her office, sabotage was becoming trendy. Kelly has seen other examples of it. It just had never happened to her. She thought all was lost, until a friend told her what other companies in the industry did when objects like this couldn't be found.
凯利怀疑是她的老板偷了照片。他们知道她必须把照片还给摄影师，而且她的名誉受到威胁。如果她真的必须打电话给摄影师告诉他照片丢了，那将是非常尴尬的。在她的办公室里，搞破坏变得很时髦。凯利见过其他例子。只是从未发生在自己身上。她以为一切都完了，直到一个朋友告诉她，当这种东西找不到时，业内其他公司会怎么做。
If the situation arises, they will hire a psychic to help them locate the images. A girl gave me a number of someone who she said was certified by the state of the New York, was a crime psychic. I called her. She said, OK, I've got a half an hour for you two days from now. Come.
如果情况出现，他们会雇佣通灵师帮助他们定位图像。一个女孩给了我一个号码，她说那是纽约州认证的犯罪通灵师。我打了电话。她说，好吧，两天后我有半小时给你。过来。
Apparently once you've accepted the notion that your bosses are actually trying to sabotage you, the idea of going to a psychic just doesn't seem that crazy anymore. It seems appropriate.
显然，一旦你接受了你的老板真的在试图破坏你的想法，去找通灵师的想法就不再显得那么疯狂了。这看起来很合适。
Kelly called the psychic from her desk in plain sight of everyone, including the suspected boss. She didn't even bother lowering her voice. And then she set about following the psychic's instructions. She took Polaroid photos of the office and all the people working there. And then she got on a train to the psychic's house in Long Island. She was hoping that the psychic would be able to tell her something, anything about where the photos were. What she got was a whole lot more.
凯利在大家的众目睽睽之下从她的办公桌上给通灵师打电话，包括那个被怀疑的老板。她甚至没费心压低声音。然后她开始按照通灵师的指示行事。她拍了办公室和在那里工作的所有人的宝丽来照片。然后她乘火车去了长岛通灵师的家。她希望通灵师能告诉她关于照片在哪里的任何事情。她得到的远不止这些。
The psychic lit a cigarette while Kelly laid out the Polaroids she had taken. Then the psychic started describing the subtlest nuances of her coworkers' personalities.
通灵师点燃了一支香烟，凯利摆出了她拍的宝丽来照片。然后通灵师开始描述她同事性格中最微妙的细微差别。
Sometimes she would just say words, like, "Oh, she's so insecure." As if she was having like a whole other conversation that wasn't with me. And she'd be like, "Oh, she's not pretty. Oh." And she would start to feel sorry. And then she would be like, "Oh, OK, he doesn't like women. Not like he's gay. He just never thinks that women are worth that much."
有时她只是说一些词，比如，“哦，她太缺乏安全感了。”好像她是在和除了我以外的别人进行一场完全不同的谈话。她会说，“哦，她不漂亮。哦。”然后她开始感到同情。然后她会说，“哦，好吧，他不喜欢女人。不是因为他是同性恋。他只是从不认为女人值得那么多。”
Of all the reading rooms in all the homes of all the psychics in Long Island, Kelly walked into this one, the home of Ann, the office politics psychic. Ann had Kelly draw a little map of her office with lines indicating where everyone sat. The psychic went from desk to desk to desk, describing the office politics between Kelly's coworkers. These two are always gossiping with each other. Don't trust them. This one was your friend, but they didn't like her, so she got fired. He's sweet. You can tell him things. Then she got to Kelly's two bosses.
在长岛所有通灵师的所有家庭的所有阅读室里，凯利走进了这一间，安，办公室政治通灵师。安让凯利画了一张办公室的小地图，用线条标出每个人坐在哪里。通灵师从一个桌子走到另一个桌子，描述凯利同事之间的办公室政治。这两个总是互相嚼舌根。别相信他们。这个曾经是你的朋友，但他们不喜欢她，所以她被解雇了。他很甜。你可以告诉他事情。然后她来到了凯利的两个老板面前。
And then she said, "Oh, OK, the person who sits here talks to the person who sits here all day long."
然后她说，“哦，好吧，坐在这里的人整天和坐在这里的人说话。”
She actually drew a line between the two bosses who are sleeping with each other? She drew the line.
她真的画了一条线在两个睡在一起的老板之间？她画了那条线。
Well, she would draw a little stick person behind the desk. And then she would draw another little stick person. And she'd be like, oh, this area to this area. My two main bosses, she was saying, were constantly talking to each other all day. She went into things that I didn't even know happened, that later I found out happened. Like they went on a trip. She knew, basically, that he was living at her place. There was not anything that she didn't know. The same amount of information, with added psychic phenomenon, as if she'd been sitting next to me the whole six months.
嗯，她会在桌子后面画一个小火柴人。然后她会画另一个小火柴人。她会说，哦，这个区域到这个区域。她一直在说我的两个主要老板整天不停地在说话。她进入了连我自己都不知道发生过的事情，后来我发现发生了。比如他们去旅行了。她基本上知道他住在她家。没有什么她不知道的。同样数量的信息，加上通灵现象，就好像她在我身边坐了整整六个月一样。
I've never called Miss Cleo. I've never had a tarot reading or had my tea leaves read. I've never crossed over. But when I heard there was a psychic on Long Island who could tell who is lying about breaking the office fax machine, I had to go. I called and made an appointment. She had one stipulation for letting me come, no debunking.
我从没打过克里奥小姐的电话。我从未做过塔罗牌阅读或读过茶叶渣。我从未越界。但当我听说长岛有一个通灵师能分辨出谁在弄坏办公室传真机的事情上撒谎时，我必须去。我打了电话预约。她让我去有一个条件，不准揭穿。
Ann lives with her elderly mother and her seven year old daughter. When I get there, grandmother and granddaughter are nestled in easy chairs, watching Golden Girls. Ann is doing a reading in the back. And her mother turns to me and asks if I'm there for a reading too. I tell her I'm not.
安和她年迈的母亲以及七岁的女儿住在一起。我到的时候，祖孙俩正蜷缩在扶手椅上，看着《黄金女郎》。安在后面做阅读。她母亲转向我，问我是不是也来阅读。我告诉她不是。
We watch TV together in silence for a few minutes. And then Ann's mother turns back to me and asks if I'm there for a reading. This pattern continues for the rest of the show. I finally give in and say, yes, I'm there for a reading. Then she gives up and shuffles off to the kitchen. And I can hear her muttering under her breath, [BEEP] gypsies.
我们一起默默地看了几分钟电视。然后安的母亲转过头问我是不是来阅读的。这种模式持续了节目剩下的时间。我终于屈服说，是的，我是来阅读的。然后她放弃了，蹒跚地走向厨房。我能听到她在那儿小声嘀咕，[哔]吉普赛人。
Then Ann comes in and takes me to her reading room.
然后安进来，把我带到了她的阅读室。
--the floor we kept the red carpeting. It is a root shakra. And it gives me a lot of energy, because I'm actually in a beta level sleep state. So I'm kind of groggy. And the best thing to wake you up in the morning is that nice red carpeting.
——地板我们保留了红地毯。它是根轮。它给了我很多能量，因为我实际上处于贝塔睡眠状态。所以我有点迷糊。早上叫醒你最好的东西就是那块漂亮的红地毯。
Ann's reading room looks like a suburban guest bedroom. There is a daybed that she likes because it makes it feel more like a therapist's office, pictures of her family, and a TV cluttered with chachkas, like a jar labeled, ashes of problem customers.
安的阅读室看起来像一间郊区客房。有一张她喜欢的日床，因为它让它感觉更像治疗师的办公室，她的家庭照片，还有摆满小饰品的电视，比如一个贴着“问题客户的骨灰”标签的罐子。
Ann prefers to be called a clairaudient trance medium, which means that she can hear stuff that isn't there, as opposed to seeing stuff that isn't there. She goes into a trance, and then her three spirit guides feed her the information.
安更喜欢被称为通灵传声媒介，这意味着她能听到不存在的东西，而不是看到不存在的东西。她进入恍惚状态，然后她的三个灵魂向导把信息传给她。
When I talked to Ann on the phone, she told me she would be in a trance when I got there. In fact, she had been in a trance when she told me that. It turns out Ann is almost always in a trance. At her house, I saw her receive payment for her services, recommend a good restaurant, and usher her client to the door, all while in a trance. This seemed to be a complete abuse of the word trance, not to be debunkey or anything.
当我在电话里和安谈话时，她告诉我当我到那里时她会进入恍惚状态。事实上，当她告诉我想法时她就在恍惚状态中。事实证明安几乎总是处于恍惚状态。在她家，我看到她接收服务费，推荐一家好餐厅，并引导她的客户出门，全程都在恍惚中。这看起来完全是对“恍惚”这个词的滥用，不是要揭穿什么。
Appointments with Ann are hard to get. She'll take anybody, but she is usually booked months in advance. People come for the usual stuff, like channeling dead relatives. But she does a big business of finding lost objects. And a large percentage of her clients come about problems at work.
安的预约很难拿到。她会接待任何人，但通常几个月前就订满了。人们来是为了常见的事情，比如引导死去的亲人。但她做了一大笔找失物的生意。而且很大一部分客户是因为工作问题而来的。
If you think about it, that's where you spend most of your waking time during the day, in most cases, is in offices. That's why there are so many issues that people have-- the variety of issues, I couldn't begin to count or measure. You name it, I've had them all.
如果你想一想，那是你白天清醒时间大部分时间所在的地方，在大多数情况下，是在办公室。这就是为什么人们有这么多问题——问题的种类，我无法开始计数或衡量。你说得出来，我全都遇到过。
I watch Ann's clients drift in and out of her home from morning till night. And what I learn is this-- it doesn't matter that the people work in different kinds of jobs, all their stories are the same. There's the cop with the corrupt boss intent on making his life hell.
我看着安的客户从早到晚在她的家中进进出出。我学到的是——人们从事不同工作并不重要，他们所有的故事都是一样的。有那个拥有意图让他的生活变得像地狱的腐败老板的警察。
You know, you could be sitting in a room with five people. He would walk in and say hello to the other four, and just ignore me like I wasn't there.
你知道，你可以和一个房间里的五个人坐在一起。他会走进来，和另外四个人打招呼，只是无视我，好像我不在那儿一样。
There's a woman from the car rental agency with a boss who didn't like women.
有一个来自汽车租赁机构的女人，她的老板不喜欢女人。
He had already been responsible for firing the two other girls in the office. I was the last remaining female.
他已经负责解雇了办公室里的另外两个女孩。我是最后一个剩下的女性。
This woman from the phone company who worked with a lot of people younger than her.
这个来自电话公司的女人，和很多比她年轻的人一起工作。
There were a few managers I had a problem with. She was the type that will laugh in your face, but she actually did you in behind your back.
我有几个经理遇到过问题。她是那种当面嘲笑你，但实际上在背后做掉你的人。
Talking to Ann about all this, every office is Othello, full of jealousy, and greed, and intrigue. Kelly's story wasn't surprising to her at all.
和安谈论这一切，每个办公室都是奥赛罗，充满了嫉妒、贪婪和阴谋。凯利的故事对她来说一点也不令人惊讶。
Surprise me? Not much of it, honestly, because I find it very common in the workplace. And very oftentimes enough, there is a lot of backstabbing.
惊讶我吗？老实说，没怎么惊讶，因为我发现这在职场中很常见。而且很多时候，背后捅刀子的事情确实很多。
At some point, I'm guessing, you have worried about investing too much emotional energy in your colleagues, your boss, your work. At least we're all doing it. In fact, for Kelly one of the best things about going to Ann about the missing photos is that Ann didn't view her freak out as excessive.
我想，在某个时候，你一定担心过在同事、老板、工作上投入过多的情感能量。至少我们都在这么做。事实上，对凯利来说，关于丢失的照片去找安的最好的事情之一是，安并没有认为她的抓狂是过分的。
Up until that point, I would be calling my mom saying, they've taken them. They have taken them. I know they have. And she would be totally freaked out, as all of my friends were. And they were like, let it go. You're going to find them. And I would be like, no, no. This is bad. This is a horrible place. And I'd be going on these rants. And my friends and my family were trying to be OK about it. But she was the first person that was like, oh, yeah, this is bad. And you're right, and that's unfortunate.
在那之前，我会给妈妈打电话说，他们拿走了。他们拿走了。我知道他们拿了。她会完全抓狂，就像我所有的朋友一样。他们说，放手吧。你会找到它们的。我会说，不，不。这很糟糕。这是一个可怕的地方。我会进行这些咆哮。我的朋友和家人试图表现得还好。但她是第一个说，哦，是的，这很糟糕。你是对的，那很不幸。
And I said, well, I brought photos. So I wanted to show her the photos, to show her the different places in the office. And she, basically, looked at the first one-- which was a Polaroid of all the guys in the office-- and said, oh, that's him. He was really mad when you were taking that photo, because he knew that you were coming here.
我说，嗯，我带来了照片。所以我想要给她看照片，给她看办公室里不同的地方。她基本上一看第一张——那是办公室里所有男人的宝丽来照片——就说，哦，那是他。当你拍那张照片时他真的很生气，因为他知道你要来这里。
The man she pointed to was Kelly's boss.
她指的男人是凯利的老板。
He is red in the face in this photo, glaring at me. His veins on his neck are sticking out. And it looks like he could probably hit me.
照片里的他满脸通红，瞪着我。他脖子上的静脉突出来。看起来他很可能会打我。
How much actual clairvoyance was involved in this is anyone's guess. Ann's clients all swear by her, love her actually. But Ann and her clients all say that a part of what Ann does is confirm what you already know. Kelly suspected her bosses. Ann told her she was right to. Armed with this new knowledge, Kelly did absolutely nothing. She didn't confront her bosses or go over their heads to the head of the company. She didn't do anything. She didn't need to. She felt better.
这其中涉及到多少实际的超感官知觉是任何人的猜测。安的客户都相信她，实际上很爱她。但安和她的客户都说，安所做的一部分是证实你已经知道的事情。凯利怀疑她的老板。安告诉她是对的。有了这些新知识，凯利什么也没做。她没有和老板对质，也没有越过他们去找公司主管。她什么也没做。她不需要。她感觉好多了。
I felt totally vindicated. I felt released after Ann. Yeah, I totally felt release, because before I went to her I kept waiting for them to break. I kept thinking that maybe they'd tell me, or that they would admit to it, or that they would just put them on my desk at night, and I would come in in the morning and then they would be there. I have had fantasies about that a lot.
我感到完全被证实了。我在安之后感到解脱。是的，我完全感到了释放，因为在她那里之前我一直等着他们崩溃。我一直想也许他们会告诉我，或者他们会承认，或者他们会在晚上把它们放在我的桌子上，我早上进来然后它们就会在那里。我经常幻想那样。
And then afterward, I didn't have to worry anymore. I had no suspicions. I knew that everything that I had thought, she had told me was true. And I stopped caring. I felt like I could look at them from a different angle. And it wasn't personal anymore. It was just more like, wow, that's pretty pathetic.
然后之后，我不用再担心了。我没有怀疑。我知道我所想的一切，她都告诉我说是真的。我停止了关心。我觉得我可以从不同的角度看他们。而且不再是私人的了。它更像是，哇，那太可悲了。
The lost photos were never found, just like Ann said they wouldn't be. Kelly now works somewhere else. Ann is booked through next summer.
丢失的照片从未找到，就像安说的那样它们不会被找到。凯利现在在别的地方工作。安的预约排到了明年夏天。
The problem with office politics is it never really makes sense outside the office. Your friends and family will never fully understand what it is you hate so much about the girl down the hall. With Ann, not only does she seem to understand, you don't even have to tell her about it.
办公室政治的问题在于它在办公室外从来没有真正的意义。你的朋友和家人永远不会完全理解你为什么那么讨厌大厅尽头的那个女孩。有了安，她不仅似乎理解，你甚至不需要告诉她。
Starlee Kine is one of the producers of our show.
斯塔莉·凯恩是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "LOVE IS ALL AROUND (MARY TYLER MOORE THEME)" BY JOAN JETT AND THE BLACKHEARTS]
[音乐 - “爱无处不在 (玛丽·泰勒·摩尔主题曲)”，琼·杰特和黑心乐队]
Act Two, Sheetcakes in the Conference Room, Whiskey After Dark. Americans are, as everybody knows, spending more time on the job, which means more people's social lives are organized around their work lives, and more holidays are celebrated more intensely, and mean more, on the job site. David Rakoff wrote this next story while we at This American Life took our show on the road a little while back, doing our show before live audiences around the country. It is a parable of three such holidays as celebrated on the job.
第二幕，“会议室里的纸蛋糕，深夜的威士忌”。众所周知，美国人花在工作上的时间越来越多，这意味着更多人的社交生活是围绕工作生活组织的，更多的节日被更强烈地庆祝，在工作场所意义更大。大卫·拉科夫写下了这个故事，当时我们《美国生活》的节目去路上巡演，在全国各地的现场观众面前表演。这是一个关于在工作中庆祝的三个此类节日的寓言。
Holiday, the first. National Secretaries Day. At least, we consoled ourselves, we were assistants, not secretaries. In the world we were in, the world of New York publishing, these titles meant everything. It's a loathsome distinction, the almost meaningless difference between field and house slave. After all, we all of us-- secretaries and assistants alike-- had much the same duties. Filing, photocopying, taking dictation, and making reservations for meals we would never get to eat. There was one glaring discrepancy between us and the secretaries, specifically their salaries dwarfed ours. But our penury came with the promise that we were bound for better things. We would be mentored, promoted, and one day raised to our rightful stations as book editors, our faith in the East Coast meritocracy restored.
节日，第一。全国秘书日。至少，我们安慰自己，我们是助理，不是秘书。在我们所处的出版世界中，这些头衔意味着一切。这是一种令人厌恶的区别，实地奴隶和家内奴隶之间几乎毫无意义的差别。毕竟，我们所有人——秘书和助理一样——都有大致相同的职责。归档、复印、听写、预订那些我们永远吃不上的饭菜。我们和秘书之间有一个明显的差异，特别是他们的工资远高于我们。但我们的贫困伴随着一个承诺，即我们注定会有更好的前程。我们将得到指导、晋升，有一天被提升到我们应有的职位——图书编辑，我们在东海岸精英制度中的信仰得以恢复。
Still every April when National Secretaries Day rolled around, many of us took sick days, genuinely nauseous with worry that we might be mistook for them, and there on our assistant's desks would be the asparagus fern and baby's breath-surrounded long stem roses, with the heartfelt note from the boss who just couldn't do it without you.
尽管如此，每到四月全国秘书日，我们许多人都会请病假，真心地因担心被误认为他们而感到恶心，在那里，在我们的助理办公桌上，会出现那些被芦笋蕨和满天星环绕的长茎玫瑰，并附上老板那句“没有你我真办不到”的衷心便条。
Instead of National Secretaries Day, we assistants had our own folk traditions with our own holidays, one of which we celebrated often, almost nightly, in fact. We called it drinking. With disturbing regularity, the end of the workday found us at the old Monkey Bar, the Dorset Bar, the [? Warwick ?] Bar, all of which were attached to serviceable and somewhat down-at-heel hotels. Midtown Manhattan used to be full of just such comfortably shabby establishments, where career waiters with Brilliantined comb overs and shiny-elbowed jackets served marvelously cheap, albeit watery, drinks, along with free snacks. Withered celery sticks, unironic faux Asian Pu Pu platters, pretzel nuggets accompanying a cheese spread of a color that in nature usually signals, I am an alluring, yet highly poisonous tree frog. Beware.
除了全国秘书日，我们助理有自己的民间传统和节日，其中一个我们庆祝得很多，事实上几乎每晚都在庆祝。我们称之为“喝酒”。令人不安的是，下班时间总是把我们带到老猴子酒吧，多塞酒吧，[？沃里克？]酒吧，所有这些都附属于平庸且有些破旧的旅馆。曼哈顿中城曾经到处都是这样舒适而寒酸的场所，头发涂满发油、袖口油亮的职业侍者服务着极好的廉价、尽管有点冲的饮料，以及免费小吃。枯萎的芹菜条，非讽刺的仿亚裔普普拼盘，配有奶酪抹酱的椒盐脆饼块，那种颜色在自然界中通常表示，“我是一只有吸引力但剧毒的树蛙。小心。”
Dinner and forgetfulness, all for $10. Youth is not wasted on the young. It is perpetrated on the young.
晚餐和遗忘，总共10美元。青春不是浪费在年轻人身上。它是强加在年轻人身上的。
Hooch, happily, was one luxury we could afford. Our drunkenness was twofold. First, there was the liquor. But there was also the intoxication brought on by the self aggrandizing conviction that we happy few, we cheery booze hounds, were the new incarnations of that most mythic bunch of souses, the Algonquin Round Table. This pipe dream sustained not just us, but I suspect countless other tables of publishing menials all over town. So desperate were we to assume the mantles of Parker, Benchley, and their ilk, that we weren't going to let some silly thing like a dearth of wit or the complete absence of a body of work on any of our parts deter us.
幸好，酒是我们唯一能负担得起的奢侈品。我们的醉酒是双重的。首先，有酒精。但也有那种自我膨胀的信念所带来的陶醉，即我们这几个幸运儿，我们这些快乐的酒鬼，是那个最神秘的酒鬼群体——阿尔冈昆圆桌会议——的新化身。这个白日梦支撑的不只是我们，我怀疑整个城里无数其他桌子的出版杂工们也是如此。我们如此渴望承载帕克、本奇利和他们那类人的衣钵，以至于我们不会让那种微不足道的机智匮乏或我们所有人都没有作品集这样的小事阻挡我们。
With enough $4 drinks sloshing through our veins, even the most dunderheaded schoolyard japery qualified as coruscating repartee. What do you want, a repose might begin, a medal or a chest to pin it on? Oh, touche, we cried merrily, as we clutched our martinis.
只要血管里流淌着足够多4美元的饮料，即使是最迟钝的学校操场上的戏谑也能算作熠熠生辉的机智问答。你想干什么，有人可能会开始反问，一枚奖章还是一个用来别奖章的胸膛？哦，触动人心，我们快乐地喊着，同时紧握我们的马提尼。
That represented the high point of the discourse. Gradually, our tongues thickened and our moods darkened unpleasantly. As the evenings wore on, a hostile, gin-scented pole fell over everything. And our glittering aphorisms were reduced to the wishful and direct, I hope my boss is dead right now.
那代表了谈话的高潮。渐渐地，我们的舌头变厚，情绪变得不快。随着夜晚的深入，一种敌对的、充满杜松子酒味的氛围笼罩了一切。而我们闪闪发光的警句被归结为充满愿望且直接的，“我希望我的老板现在就死掉。”
Paying the bill, we stumbled out into the street and back to our apartments, where we spent the rest of the night jealously reading the manuscripts of those who actually wrote and didn't just drink about it. Rising unrefreshed, we would return to the office, and-- rubbing alcohol and cotton balls in hand-- get down to work swabbing, leaf by leaf, the potted plants in our boss' office, a vain attempt to stop the outbreak of white fly that was going around the floor.
付了账，我们跌跌撞撞地走到街上，回到了我们的公寓，在那里我们花剩下的时间嫉妒地阅读那些真正写作而不只是喝醉了在那儿谈论它的人的手稿。带着没睡好的疲惫，我们回到办公室，——拿着外用酒精和棉球——开始工作，一片叶子一片叶子地擦拭老板办公室里的盆栽植物，试图阻止在楼层里传播的白粉虱。
Impressing the higher ups became our constant purpose. We spent an inordinate amount of time attaching disproportionate significance to our message taking skills, our collating acumen, no small feat from under a hovering cloud of job hatred. How sad to realize, from the vantage point of years later, that the answer to the question that was perpetually on our minds, what do they think of me, was-- they didn't at all. Realistically, we were the help. And it was best not to forget it.
给上司留下好印象成了我们永恒的目标。我们花费了不成比例的时间在我们的信息接收技能、整理能力上附加了过高的意义，从对工作仇恨的云雾中做出的成就。多年后从这个角度看，意识到我们脑海中一直存在的问题的答案——他们怎么看我——是——他们根本没怎么看。现实地说，我们是帮手。最好不要忘记这一点。
Holiday, the second. Christmas. Those three weeks or so of midtown Manhattan Christmas are an assistant's dream. No work gets done. And all is romanticized melancholy. It was precisely why so many of us had moved to the city, so that we too might gaze misanthropically at the corporate Christmas tree in the lobby surrounded with gift-wrapped empty boxes that fooled nobody, and in the institutional fluorescent-lit sadness of it all, feel something approaching depth. The phones idle, we spent our days going to the movies during lunch, returning hours later to troll the halls of the office, foraging through the gift baskets like a ravening pack of voles, subsisting on Carr's water biscuits, individually red waxed thick balls of baby Gouda, butternut toffee, popcorn, smoke house almonds, and fancy fruit preserves eaten directly from the jar. A diet that had our faces peppered with blackheads and glistening with oily sebum as unto the shining visages of the apostles.
节日，第二。圣诞节。曼哈顿中城的圣诞节那三周左右是助理的梦想。什么工作都做不成。一切都是浪漫化的忧郁。这正是我们许多人搬到这个城市的原因，这样我们也可能愤世嫉俗地凝视着大堂里的企业圣诞树，上面堆满了没人会上当的包装精美的空盒子，在这一切制度化的荧光灯悲伤中，感受到接近深度感的东西。电话闲置，我们白天午餐时去看电影，几小时后回来在办公室的走廊里游荡，像一群贪婪的田鼠一样翻找礼品篮，靠卡尔水饼干、单独红蜡封的厚大高地奶酪球、奶油太妃糖、爆米花、烟熏杏仁和直接从罐子里吃的花式果酱维持生命。这种饮食让我们的脸上长满了黑头，泛着油腻的皮脂，就像使徒们闪亮的脸庞。
Our bosses were away with their families at country houses having real lives. We wondered how they might greet the sight of the empty food baskets upon their return, such anarchy, such transgression. As usual, they never even noticed. We on the other hand, could not even conceive of a world wherein we did not know the exact quantity and location of our giant cashews.
我们的老板和家人在乡村别墅里过着真正的生活。我们想知道当他们回来时看到空空的食物篮会作何感想，这种无政府状态，这种越界。像往常一样，他们甚至从来没有注意到。另一方面，我们甚至无法想象一个我们不知道我们巨大腰果确切数量和位置的世界。
Holiday, the third. Happy Birthday. After any moment of extreme assistant subjugation, say a morning wherein one might innocently open an unsolicited manuscript only to find that someone had mailed the publishing house a jiffy pack full of human feces. Or one might be sent to the corner to pick up a cappuccino for an author who had just been given a $1 million book advance, a coffee for which I was not reimbursed. After such moments, we would make our way to Sheila's cubicle, where we could always be guaranteed clear-eyed advice and cigarettes. Sheila was our bad girl leader. A poet and writer herself, she despised her job, and didn't care who knew it, smoking openly at her desk and standing on ceremony for no one. "These would be my pajamas that I slept in last night," she would say, indicating the black long sleeve T-shirt and black workout pants she was wearing. "And this," she would add, fingering a crusted white smear on the hem of the top, "this would be spilled food. Nice." Well, they say, dress for the job you want not the job you have.
节日，第三。生日快乐。在任何极端的助理压迫时刻之后，比如一个早上，有人可能会无辜地打开一份未经请求的手稿，结果发现有人给出版社寄来了一个装满人类粪便的包裹。或者有人可能会被派到拐角处为一位刚刚获得100万美元图书预付款的作家买卡布奇诺，那一杯咖啡我没有得到报销。在这样的时刻之后，我们会走到希拉的隔间，那里我们总是能保证得到清醒的建议和香烟。希拉是我们坏女孩的领袖。她自己也是诗人兼作家，她鄙视这份工作，并不在乎谁知道，在办公桌上公开抽烟，不向任何人讲究礼节。“这些是我昨晚睡觉穿的睡衣，”她会说，示意她穿着的黑色长袖T恤和黑色运动裤。“还有这个，”她会补充道，摸着上衣下摆上的一块硬化的白色污渍，“这大概是溢出的食物。真不错。”嗯，人们说，为了你想要的工作着装，而不是你现在的工作。
So of course, it was immediately to Sheila that I went when I received my birthday card. It was late November. Opening the envelope, my eyes fell upon it, a reproduction of one of those tinted B movie stills from the 1950s. A woman in a smart worsted business jacket wearing a pair of glasses at which men seldom make passes, and a switchboard operator's headset out of which were shooting tiny lightning bolts, was shown to be thinking, someone needs coffee.
所以当然，当我收到生日卡片时，我立刻去找了希拉。那是十一月下旬。打开信封，我的目光落在了上面，那是1950年代那些带色的B级电影剧照之一。一个穿着时髦精纺商务夹克的女人，戴着一副男人们很少会搭讪的眼镜，戴着接线员的耳机，耳机里射出微小的闪电，显示她在想，有人需要咖啡。
Above her head, in screaming sci-fi acid yellow type, was the title of this card's purported movie, The Amazing Tale of the Psychic Secretary. I slid the card back into the envelope, walked over, and showed it to her. "Get your coat," she said, her voice businesslike, her face unreadable. We went to the [? Warwick ?] Bar. "Don't talk for a while, just smoke," she said. And then as an afterthought, she added, "But you knew I was going to say that, didn't you, psychic secretary?"
在她头上方，用尖叫的科幻酸黄色字体写着这张卡片假定的电影标题，《通灵秘书的神奇故事》。我把卡片滑回信封，走过去，展示给她看。“拿上你的外套，”她说，声音公事公办，脸色让人看不透。我们去了[？沃里克？]酒吧。“先别说话，抽烟就行，”她说。然后作为事后的想法，她补充道，“但你知道我会这么说，不是吗，通灵秘书？”
Across from us in the darkened booth, a couple sat, a man and a woman. They had clearly been there for hours, because the woman's head was lolling about on her neck as she alternately whispered lubriciously or laughed too heartily at her companion's jokes. We had a clear view under the table, where we could see her rubbing ever higher up his thigh. I knew where this exchange was leading. Psychic.
在我们对面昏暗的隔间里，坐着一对男女。他们显然已经在那里坐了几个小时了，因为那个女人的头在脖子上晃来晃去，一边淫荡地低语，一边对她同伴的笑话笑得过于热烈。我们在桌下有一个清晰的视野，可以看到她揉搓着他的大腿越往上。我知道这种交换会导致什么。通灵。
Not long after that evening, I sat in a movie theater packed to the rafters. Just before the lights went down, a woman marched up the aisle, looked at me, and asked, "Is that seat taken?" I was nowhere near the end of the row, but trying to be helpful, I asked, "Which seat?" Looking directly into my eyes, she said, "That seat." She pointed. She was pointing to the center of my chest, to my very heart. "Well, I'm sitting here," I managed finally.
那天晚上之后不久，我坐在挤满了人的电影院里。灯灭之前，一个女人顺着走廊走过来，看着我，问道，“那个座位有人吗？”我离过道尽头还很远，但试图帮忙，我问道，“哪个座位？”她直接看着我的眼睛说，“那个座位。”她指着。她指着我胸口的中心，我的心。最后我勉强说道，“嗯，我坐在这儿。”
As if I were her college age daughter who had suddenly announced that I was a vegetarian, she shrugged in a kind of suit yourself indulgence of my fantasy of existence, and moved on. I looked up and down the row for some sort of laughter, some eye rolling commiseration, or just plain corroboration that this had just happened. But I got no response. To this day I can not explain it. Was this an emissary sent from on high at that time of year, not to trumpet the birth of the son of God, but to proclaim with heavenly proof my complete and utter insignificance?
就像我是她的大学生女儿突然宣布我是素食主义者一样，她耸了耸肩，带着一种对我存在幻觉的纵容，继续走开了。我上下看了一眼这一排，想看看有没有笑声，有没有翻白眼的同情，或者仅仅是证实刚刚发生了这种事。但我没有得到任何回应。直到今天我也无法解释。这是一个在那个一年中的那个时候从天而降的使者，不是为了吹响上帝之子的诞生，而是为了以天上的证据宣示我完全而彻底的微不足道吗？
She's right, I thought. This seat isn't taken. It was the perfect moment for that time in my life. I mean that, of course, in the worst way possible. The theater went dark. Up on the screen, the camera zoomed past a huge closeup of the Statue of Liberty, swooping down to find the Staten Island Ferry scudding along the water, transporting our working girl to her office job, where we already knew she would triumph, vanquish the harpy boss, and win the love of the man.
她是正确的，我想。这个座位没有人。那是我一生中那个时刻的完美时刻。当然，我的意思是最糟糕的方式。电影院变黑了。银幕上，摄像机掠过自由女神像巨大的特写镜头，猛冲下来寻找在水面上飞驰的斯塔滕岛渡轮，把我们的工作女孩运送到她的办公室工作，在那里我们已经知道她会胜利，战胜那个刻薄的老板，赢得那个男人的爱。
Sheila taught me a survival technique for getting through seemingly intolerable situations, interminable lunches, stern lectures on attitude or time management, being trapped by the office bore beside the sheetcake in the conference room, and the like. Maintaining eye contact, keep your face inscrutable and mask-like with the faintest hint of a smile. Keep this up as long as you possibly can. And just as you feel you're about to crack and take a letter opener and plunge it into someone's neck, fold your hands in your lap, one nestled inside the other, like those of a supplicant in a priory. Now with the index finger of your inner hand, write on the palm of the other, very discreetly and undetectably, I hate you, I hate you, I hate you, over and over again as you pretend to listen.
希拉教了我一种生存技巧，用来度过看似无法忍受的情况，无休止的午餐，关于态度或时间管理的严厉讲座，被困在会议室纸蛋糕旁边的办公室无聊的人，等等。保持眼神交流，保持你的脸不可捉摸，像面具一样，带着一丝淡淡的微笑。尽量坚持。就在你觉得要崩溃、想拿信封刀刺入某人脖子的时候，双手合十，交叠在膝盖上，就像修道院里的祈祷者一样。现在用内侧那只手的手指，非常隐蔽和不可察觉地在另一只手的手掌上写下，“我恨你，我恨你，我恨你”，一遍又一遍，同时假装在听。
You will find that this brings a spontaneous look of interest and pleased engagement to your countenance. Continue and repeat as necessary. In the dark of the theater, I write my message, pressing hard into the flesh of my hand. Although I don't know who I am writing to, I'm just glad to feel that it hurts. Thank you.
你会发现这会给你的面容带来一种自发的兴趣和愉悦的投入感。继续并根据需要重复。在黑暗的电影院里，我写下我的信息，用力压入我手心的肉里。虽然我不知道我在写给谁，但我只是很高兴感觉到它很痛。谢谢。
David Rakoff. He put a version of this story into his first book, which is called Fraud. Coming up, Philip Glass, Spike Lee, and Stephen Hawking sit around, have a casual conversation about, you know, whatever. That will be the day. In a minute, from Public Radio International and Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
大卫·拉科夫。他把这个故事的一个版本放进了他的第一本书里，书名叫《欺诈》。接下来，菲利普·格拉斯、斯派克·李和斯蒂芬·霍金坐在一起，进行了一次随意的谈话，关于，你知道，随意的任何事。那将是那一天。稍后，来自国际公共电台和芝加哥公共电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Office Politics. High drama in our nation's workplaces. We have arrived at Act Three. Act Three, When the Job to Get You off the Streets is on the Streets.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种不同种类的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，《办公室政治》。我们国家职场中的高强度戏剧。我们来到了第三幕。第三幕，“当为了让你远离街头的职业就在街头上时”。
In New York City, at Sixth Avenue and Eighth Street in Greenwich Village, pretty much any day you will see tables on the sidewalks, manned by scruffy-looking men. This extends for two blocks. What they are selling on the tables are magazines and books. Most of these have been pulled from the trash, found in dumpsters. Julie Snyder reports on the politics of this particular business.
在纽约市，格林威治村的第六大道和第八街，几乎每天你都会看到人行道上有桌子，由衣着邋遢的男人把守。这延伸了两个街区。他们在桌子上卖的是杂志和书。大多数是从垃圾里捡来的，在垃圾箱里发现的。朱莉·斯奈德报道了这个特定行业的政治。
After spending a couple of days on the corner of Sixth Avenue and Eighth Street, what strikes me is not how different street vending is from other businesses, but how similar. As if the rules of business are so deeply encoded in us that as soon as anyone starts to sell anything, in any setting, the rules and hierarchies of a company start to gel around them, even if what they're doing is selling other people's trash.
在第六大道和第八街的拐角处待了几天后，打动我的不是街头小贩与其他生意有多么不同，而是多么相似。就好像商业规则深深地编码在我们体内，以至于只要有人开始在任何环境下卖任何东西，公司的规则和等级制度就会开始在他们周围凝固，即使他们做的是卖别人的垃圾。
On the corner, you've got your entry levels, and you've got the people who have worked and clawed their way to the top. That's more or less what Ishmael Walker did. When I visit, he has the best spot on the block, right on the corner, in front of the Barnes & Noble. And what got him there was simple ambition.
在拐角处，你有你的初级职位，还有那些工作并爬到顶端的人。这或多或少就是伊斯梅尔·沃克所做的。当我访问时，他在街区有最好的位置，就在拐角处，在巴诺书店前面。让他到达那里的原因是简单的野心。
At one time, I was down the block. I was just sitting out. I said, damn all the money is up there and everybody up there. Because see, that bookstore, people go and buy books, right? And I've got books on the table. I've got magazines. I might just got what they want.
有一次，我在街区下方。我只是坐在外面。我说，该死，钱都在上面，每个人都在上面。因为你看，那家书店，人们去买书，对吧？我的桌子上有书。我有杂志。我可能正好有他们想要的东西。
There were other reasons Ishmael wanted the corner. Right across is Gray's Papaya, a hot dog restaurant with plate glass windows that looks directly onto the corner. When it rains, he can sit inside and eat and still keep an eye on his stuff. Also, there's a small alcove that is right in front of Ishmael's table, where he keeps a chair and can relax or nap during the day.
伊斯梅尔想要这个拐角还有其他原因。对面是Gray's Papaya，一家热狗餐厅，有可以直接看到拐角的平板玻璃窗。下雨时，他可以坐在里面吃，同时还能留意他的东西。此外，在伊斯梅尔的桌子前面有一个小壁龛，他在那里放了一把椅子，白天可以在那里放松或打盹。
To understand how you rise to the best space on the block, or how you get demoted to the worst, consider Ron's story.
要了解你是如何上升到街区最好的空间，或者你是如何被降级到最差的，考虑一下罗恩的故事。
I told you one time I had this whole block from the light post to the light post. This was when I first came out here.
我告诉过你，有一次我从灯柱到灯柱拥有整个街区。那是我第一次来到这里的时候。
Ron is at the very end of the blocks in what is, arguably, the worst location. Years ago, before Ishmael made his move to the top, Ron controlled the entire block, including the area where Ishmael is now.
罗恩在街区的最尽头，处于可以说最差的位置。几年前，在伊斯梅尔向上升迁之前，罗恩控制着整个街区，包括伊斯梅尔现在所在的区域。
Now how I got control of this whole block was that I was living here. I was living right here on the sidewalk. There was no way anybody was going to get here before me. You understand? And I used to sleep over there. Me and a few other guys used to sleep over there. I packed my stuff up in a dumpster, a post office thing. And I would push it over there. You understand, I could be up 24 four hours if I wanted.
现在我如何控制整个街区的，是因为我住在这里。我当时就住在人行道上。没有人能比我先到这里。你明白吗？我过去常睡在那边。我和几个其他人过去常睡在那边。我把东西打包在一个垃圾箱里，一个邮局的东西。我会把它推到那边。你明白，如果我想，我可以24小时不睡觉。
More than half the guys on Sixth Avenue are homeless. So it's easier for them to stay with their stuff and keep their spaces on the street. Eventually, Ron moved in with his aunt in Harlem. He lost control of the block, and now he doesn't get as much business as Ishmael does. He's away from all the action. But it's just not worth it to Ron anymore.
第六大道上超过一半的人是无家可归的。所以他们留下来看管他们的东西并保持他们在街上的空间更容易。最终，罗恩搬去和他在哈莱姆区的姑妈一起住。他失去了对街区的控制，现在他不像伊斯梅尔那样能做那么多生意了。他远离了所有的行动。但对罗恩来说已经不值得了。
Because I'm not going to stay out here all night to hold down a spot. I have got a place to live now. You understand? I'm going to pack my stuff up at night and go home.
因为我不会整晚待在这里守住一个位置。我现在有住的地方了。你明白吗？我会把东西打包回家。
The way Ron started here is the way all the guys start. He was a panhandler. But you're lucky if you get any of the guys to admit that, because for the most part, the vendors are embarrassed about their panhandling past. The panhandlers, meanwhile, look down on the vendors, saying they have too much pride to sell someone else's trash. Ron remembers panhandling as just being humiliating.
罗恩在这里开始的方式是所有家伙开始的方式。他是个乞丐。但如果你能让任何家伙承认这一点你就算走运了，因为大部分情况下，小贩对他们的乞讨过去感到羞耻。与此同时，乞丐看不起小贩，说他们有太多的自尊，不去卖别人的垃圾。罗恩记得乞讨只是令人羞辱。
I was panhandling over there on Ninth Street. And I remember one day I walked up to my brother-in-law. I didn't walk up to him. I was panhandling-- my back was turned. And he walked up. And I turned around and said, spare some change. And it was my brother-in-law. And he looked at me like-- he said, I have got a wife and kids to support. And he kept going.
我当时在第九街乞讨。我记得有一天我走到我妹夫那里。我没走到他那里。我当时在乞讨——我背对着他。他走了过来。我转过身说，给点零钱吧。原来是我妹夫。他看着我，好像——他说，我有妻子和孩子要养。然后他继续走。
And one time I was really embarrassed. This time, I was working at this job as a time keeper. And I was getting good money. And I ended up leaving that job, because I'm out drinking. One of the coworkers that I didn't really get along with that good was a girl. And she had a boyfriend. Her boyfriend was a New Jersey cop. And I remember one day I was panhandling uptown. And she walked up, and she looked at me like she was real startled. And she was with the guy. And I remember I was real being embarrassed that time. So I'm actually glad that I was able to start vending, which is more respectable.
有一次我真的很尴尬。那次，我在做一个考勤员的工作。我赚了不少钱。我最终离开了那份工作，因为我出去喝酒了。我相处得不太好的同事之一是个女孩。她有个男朋友。她的男朋友是新泽西警察。我记得有一天我在住宅区乞讨。她走了过来，她看着我，好像非常吃惊。她和那个家伙在一起。我记得那次我真的很尴尬。所以我其实很高兴我能开始摆摊，那更体面。
When you spend time on the corner, what it looks like is there will be 20 or 30 guys all around the tables. And it seems like they're just hanging out do nothing. But it turns out they all have different and distinct jobs, with different responsibilities and pay scales. There are place holders, who camp out overnight on the sidewalk, holding a space that they sell to vendors in the morning. That usually pays around $20 to $30. Guys called storage providers have places either in their apartments, or under the subway tracks, or in empty store rooms, where they charge $7 to $10 for the vendors to keep their tables and crates of magazines during the night. The movers help the vendors haul their stuff on and off the sidewalks. They generally make $5 to $10 a move.
当你花时间在拐角处时，看起来会有20或30个家伙在桌子周围。看起来他们只是什么都不做地闲逛。但事实证明他们都有不同且独特的职业，有不同的责任和工资标准。有占位符，他们整晚宿营在人行道上，占据一个空间，然后在早上卖给小贩。那通常能赚20到30美元。被称为存储提供商的人在他们的公寓里、地铁轨道下或空储藏室里有地方，他们收取7到10美元，让小贩晚上存放他们的桌子和杂志箱。搬运工帮助小贩把他们的东西拉上和拉下人行道。他们通常每次搬运赚5到10美元。
If you were to show up on Sixth Avenue tomorrow to start in the business, even with a high school or college degree, even with other job experience, you'd have to work your way up, the same as anyone, before you would make vendor. When sociologist Mitch Deneier came to the block to write about the vendors, he was first put to work getting coffee and helping out in little ways for months before getting his own table. He ended up spending years with the vendors.
如果你明天出现在第六大道开始这个行业，即使有高中或大学学位，即使有其他工作经验，你也必须像其他人一样一步步往上爬，然后才能成为小贩。当社会学家米奇·德涅尔来到街区写关于小贩的事情时，他首先被派去买咖啡，并在几个月里做些小事帮忙，然后才得到自己的桌子。他最终和小贩们待了几年。
Not anybody can come out here and set up a table. You have to work your way through the system, because there's only a certain number of legal spots on the street.
不是任何人都能出来摆个摊。你必须通过系统往上爬，因为街上的合法摊位数量有限。
The city regulates how many spots there can be.
城市规定了可以有多少个位置。
And so some guys show up in the morning, and their whole job is just to be a mover. And in fact, that's how Conrad got started out here. He was originally just a mover. And now he moved up to getting his own table. And there are many people who start out as table watchers, watching a table all night while someone else goes to sleep, or watching a table while people go to the bathroom. And they may wind up having their own table one day.
所以有些家伙早上出现，他们的全部工作只是做一个搬运工。事实上，这就是康拉德在这里开始的方式。他最初只是个搬运工。现在他晋升到拥有自己的摊位。有许多人开始作为桌子观察者，整晚观察一张桌子，同时别人去睡觉，或者在人们去洗手间时观察桌子。他们最终有一天可能会有自己的摊位。
Mitch introduced me to everyone on Sixth Avenue and explained that excessive drug use is pretty much what brought all of the guys out here. Most times, a person's position on the sidewalk correlates to their level of addiction. If you smoke a lot of crack and aren't too trustworthy, a place holder is about the best job you can get. It you're pretty clean, you're probably a regular table watcher or a vendor.
米奇把我介绍给了第六大道上的每个人，并解释说过度吸毒是把这些家伙带到这里的根本原因。大多数时候，一个人在人行道上的位置与他们的成瘾程度相关。如果你吸很多快克可卡因且不太值得信任，占位符就是你能得到最好的工作了。如果你比较干净，你可能是一个常规的桌子观察者或小贩。
So there are cliques on the sidewalks and mutual snobberies between the panhandlers and the vendors. But like in any workplace, there are people who sidestep those trivialities, ignore the politics. B. A. is one of those people.
所以人行道上有小圈子，乞丐和小贩之间有相互的势利。但就像在任何工作场所，有些人避开了这些琐事，忽视了政治。B.A.就是其中之一。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] I told you that lady here, all right?
[不清楚] 我告诉过你这里的那个女士，对吧？
Some people say the B. A. stands for Bad Attitude. But B. A. prefers Business Administrator. It's an apt title for him because he's sort of a floater on Sixth Avenue, one of the few guys who jumps from job to job during the day. On this afternoon, B. A. is table watching. He is also place holding a space next to him for a vendor named Joe, an elderly white guy who sells rare and out of print books, but only comes to the sidewalks on weekends. And then on top of all of that, at 4:00 in the afternoon most days, he goes down to the PATH train station to panhandle, though today he isn't going.
有些人说B.A.代表“坏态度”。但B.A.更喜欢“商业管理员”。这对他来说是一个贴切的头衔，因为他在第六大道上算是一个漂泊者，是白天在工作中跳来跳去为数不多的几个家伙之一。在这个下午，B.A.正在观察桌子。他还在他旁边为一个名叫乔的卖书小贩留了一个空位，乔是一个老年白人，卖稀有和绝版书，但只在周末来人行道。然后最重要的是，大多数天下午4点，他会去PATH火车站乞讨，虽然今天他不打算去。
I've got somebody down there working for me.
我在下面有人为我工作。
At the train?
在火车站？
Yeah, the PATH train station.
是的，PATH火车站。
You pay somebody to go down there for you if you can't go, and then--
如果你不能去，你就付钱给别人替你去，然后——
No, they pay me when they come out. They pay me.
不，他们出来时付钱给我。他们付钱给我。
Because you have a spot down there too?
因为你在那里也有个位置？
Yeah, they take my time. Do you know what I'm saying? My time is from 4:00 to 6:00. So if they want to get on my time, I tell them, give me half. If you want to got down there from 4:00 to 6:00, give me half.
是的，他们占用我的时间。你知道我在说什么吗？我的时间是4点到6点。所以如果他们想在我的时间里，我告诉他们，给我一半。如果你想在4点到6点去那里，给我一半。
So right now you're making money down at the train station, and then you're also making money right now on the table.
所以现在你在火车站赚钱，然后你同时也在桌子上赚钱。
Of course. That's how I go.
当然。这就是我的运作方式。
And then you'll also make money tonight by holding the space for Joe for tomorrow.
然后你今晚还会通过为乔保留明天的空间赚钱。
Got it.
明白了。
What would you do if somebody just went down there from 4:00 to 6:00 and started panhandling, and you didn't know them, and they didn't pay you? Isn't that possible?
如果有人只是从4点到6点去那里开始乞讨，而你不认识他们，他们也不付你钱，你会怎么做？那不是可能的吗？
No, no, no. They've got to go. Because I go at 3:30, and I check out my spot. Do you know what I'm saying? I got out at 3:30. I go make sure everything is clear. I go set myself up, my crate down there, get my cup ready. I change my clothes to look like a bum.
不，不，不。他们必须走。因为我在3点半去，我检查我的位置。你知道我在说什么吗？我3点半出来。我确保一切清楚。我去把自己安顿好，把我的板条箱放在那里，准备好我的杯子。我换衣服让自己看起来像个流浪汉。
Wait. At the risk of making homeless advocates cringe, I want to make sure you caught that. Right now, B. A. is wearing a polo shirt from the Gap, khakis, and Adidas. But when he goes down to panhandle, he says, he changes his clothes to look like a bum.
等等。冒着让无家可归者倡导者畏缩的风险，我想确保你抓住了这一点。现在，B.A.穿着Gap的Polo衫，卡其裤和阿迪达斯。但当他去乞讨时，他说，他换衣服让自己看起来像个流浪汉。
I change my clothes to look like a bum.
我换衣服让自己看起来像个流浪汉。
You change your clothes to look like-- because right now you look really nice.
你换衣服让自己看起来像——因为现在你看起来很不错。
That's why I say I have to go change and everything.
这就是为什么我说我必须去换衣服等等。
When you have to go down and go panhandling, then what do you wear?
当你必须去乞讨时，你穿什么？
I put on my overalls or something. I change my sneakers out. You know, just [UNINTELLIGIBLE] or my do rag or something like that. You know, I just sit down and just look homeless.
我穿上我的工装裤之类的。我换掉我的运动鞋。你知道，只是[不清楚]或者我的头巾什么的。你知道，我只是坐下看起来无家可归。
And in two hours, how much can you get?
那两个小时里，你能赚多少？
$60 to $80.
60到80美元。
Hey Shorty, where you get those babies from? What's that? Magazines?
嘿，矮子，你从哪儿弄来的那些宝贝？那是啥？杂志？
At one point on the corner, Ishmael's friend, Shorty, pulls up on the sidewalk, and gets out of a cab carrying several cardboard boxes. Someone had cleaned out their apartment and given Shorty a bunch of old books.
在拐角处，伊斯梅尔的朋友，矮子，开车开到人行道上，拎着几个纸箱下了车。有人清空了他们的公寓，给了矮子一堆旧书。
You've got something up in there.
你那里面有东西。
The guys gather around and evaluate the books. Most of them seem pretty old, with titles nobody has ever heard of. But there are a few known sellers.
家伙们聚在一起评估这些书。大多数看起来很旧，有着没人听说过的标题。但有一些已知的畅销书。
Oh, look over here.
哦，看这边。
We used [UNINTELLIGIBLE] The Baby-sitters Club.
我们用过[不清楚]《保姆俱乐部》。
The Baby-sitters Club. These will sell, bro. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] A person that don't sell books or magazines don't know nothing about it.
《保姆俱乐部》。这些会卖掉的，兄弟。[不清楚]一个不卖书或杂志的人什么都不知道。
Some of these guys have known each other for over twenty years. In the mid '80s, they lived together in Penn Station, before the city cleaned it up. After time in jail and treatment programs, the guys regrouped on Sixth Avenue. And they are close in a way that makes it nice to hang out with them. They joke around. They get into little arguments that last a day or two and then blow over.
这些家伙中有些已经认识二十多年了。80年代中期，在城市清理之前，他们住在一起，在宾夕法尼亚车站。在监狱和治疗项目之后，这些家伙在第六大道重组了。他们以一种让他们在一起闲逛很舒服的方式很亲近。他们开玩笑。他们会进行持续一两天的小争吵，然后就烟消云散了。
These are all good prices, my friend.
这些都是好价钱，朋友。
How much [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
多少钱[不清楚]？
I'll give you $1 a piece on them. That's a good deal for those.
我给你每本1美元。这对那些来说是个好交易。
Starting around 4:00 in the afternoon, the sidewalks start getting busier, the music gets turned up on the stereos, and what's known as the power hour begins. Each table has about 150 to 200 magazines laid out. The sellers, Vogue, Vibe, GQ, Martha Stewart Living, Architectural Digest. There are foreign fashion magazines, like Italian Vogue and the occasional specialty order.
下午4点左右开始，人行道开始变得繁忙，音响里的音乐声调高了，被称为“力量时间”开始了。每张桌子大约摆放着150到200本杂志。《Vogue》，《Vibe》，《GQ》，《玛莎·斯图尔特生活》，《建筑文摘》。有外国时尚杂志，比如意大利版《Vogue》和偶尔的特殊订单。
I have a girl right now, she wants Drew Barrymore Playboy issue. She said on the internet they're asking $60 for it. I've had that book many times. I'm waiting on it now. I'm going to just charge her $3 or $5.
我有个女孩现在想要德鲁·巴里摩尔的《花花公子》那一期。她说在互联网上他们要价60美元。我有很多次有那本书。我现在正等着它。我打算只收她3或5美元。
The losers, any weekly magazine. The New Yorker, Sports Illustrated, Newsweek. Neighbors will often donate stacks of weekly magazines, like People, to the vendors. The vendors will take them just to be polite and later quietly throw them away.
失败者，任何周刊杂志。《纽约客》，《体育画报》，《新闻周刊》。邻居经常会把一堆周刊杂志捐给小贩，比如《人物》。小贩会为了礼貌而收下，然后静静地把它们扔掉。
It seems that smut sells the best. And there's a surprisingly large stock of gay porn that everyone is completely matter of fact about. In fact, it's all pretty relaxed, no hard sell, except for Ishmael, sitting in his premium spot at the top of the block.
看起来黄色刊物卖得最好。而且有惊人数量的同性恋色情片，每个人对此都完全实事求是。事实上，一切都很放松，没有强行推销，除了伊斯梅尔，坐在他在街区顶端的优质位置。
At one point, a cab driver, who Ishmael has apparently dealt with before, pulls up next to the tables and asks Ishmael if he has any computer books or software.
在某一点上，一个伊斯梅尔显然以前打过交道的出租车司机把车停在桌子旁边，问伊斯梅尔是否有任何计算机书籍或软件。
Yeah, right there. The whole section, the whole foot. Come on out of your cab. You've got to get up out of the cab and come on by the table, bro.
是的，就在那儿。整个部分，整个脚长。从你的出租车出来吧。你必须从出租车里出来，走到桌子边，兄弟。
The cab driver is reluctant to leave his cab parked, sitting in the middle of a lane of traffic on the side of a busy New York City street.
出租车司机很不情愿把车停在繁忙的纽约市街道的交通车道中间，不愿离开他的出租车。
You've got to come on out. You've got to get up on it. We aren't going to have that accident no more, like we did last time.
你必须出来。你必须站上来。我们不会再发生那样的事故了，像上次一样。
I don't want a ticket.
我不想吃罚单。
Don't worry about the ticket. I want you to see the books, man.
别担心罚单。我要你看这些书，伙计。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[不清楚]
Ishmael actually gets the cab driver to come out of his cab and to the table. He sells the computers book for $10.
伊斯梅尔真的让出租车司机从车里出来到了桌子旁。他以10美元的价格卖掉了那本计算机书。
Now I don't understand how you're going to see like that. You have to go around the table--
现在我不明白你怎么看。你必须绕过桌子——
What got Ishmael to the top of the block is pretty much what get someone to the top of any business. He just wanted it more. When he first started on the sidewalk, there was a guy named Scotty sitting at the corner by the bookstore. So Ishmael made a plan. He says he stayed inside, and rested up for a week, and got ready to make his move on Scotty.
让伊斯梅尔到达街区顶端的是任何生意中让一个人到达顶端的原因。他只是更想要它。当他第一次在人行道上开始时，有一个名叫斯科蒂的家伙坐在书店旁边的拐角处。所以伊斯梅尔制定了一个计划。他说他待在里面，休息了一周，准备好对斯科蒂采取行动。
So the day comes, he ain't come yet. So my tables are in there. Next minute, here he comes. Oh, boy. I fought for three mornings, three days straight, physically fighting, tables in the street, comic books in the street, books in the street.
所以那一天来了，他还没来。所以我的桌子在里面。下一分钟，他来了。哦，男孩。我为了三个早上奋斗，连续三天，身体搏斗，桌子在街上，漫画书在街上，书在街上。
You kicked his in the street?
你把他的踢到街上了？
He kicked mine, and I kicked his. For three days straight, 8 o'clock till about 11 o'clock in the morning.
他踢了我的，我踢了他的。连续三天，早上8点一直到11点左右。
When Mitch first introduced me to Ishmael, Mitch said he'd met few people in his life with the determination that Ishmael has. And I know it's weird that the path to triumph would be kicking the ass of your opponent for three hours every morning. But if Coke and Pepsi could do the same thing, don't you think they would?
当米奇第一次把我介绍给伊斯梅尔时，米奇说他一生中遇到过像伊斯梅尔这样有决心的人很少。我知道通往胜利的道路是每天早上殴打你的对手三个小时很奇怪。但如果可口可乐和百事可乐也能做同样的事，你不觉得他们会做吗？
Ishmael, I have seen you in 30 below zero weather, at 3 o'clock, 4 o'clock in the morning, I've seen you preserving this space out here when everybody else was gone.
伊斯梅尔，我在零下30度的天气里见过你，在凌晨3点、4点，我见过你在这里保护这个空间，当其他人都走了的时候。
That's right. Because it's like this. They say the ghosts come out at night. And if you're not there, believe me, somebody is waiting to slip up in there.
那是对的。因为就像这样。他们说鬼魂在晚上出来。如果你不在那里，相信我，有人等着溜进去。
On a good day, when the weather's nice and lots of people are out, Ishmael makes about $150. But he works seven days a week. And a lot of days it rains.
在天气好、人很多的好日子里，伊斯梅尔赚大约150美元。但他一周七天工作。而且很多天都在下雨。
Julie Snyder is the senior producer of our show. Mitch Deneier's book, documenting several years in the lives of the vendors, is called Sidewalk. Our thanks to him for acting as our guide for this story.
朱莉·斯奈德是我们节目的高级制作人。米奇·德涅尔的书，记录了小贩生活中几年的书名叫《人行道》。感谢他作为我们这个故事的向导。
Thanks today also to Monica Hall and Chris Neary. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
感谢今天同样来自莫妮卡·霍尔和克里斯·尼里。《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. When Spike Lee walks in on Torey, me, Philip Glass, and Stephen Hawking, this is what happens.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。当斯派克·李遇到托里、我、菲利普·格拉斯和斯蒂芬·霍金时，发生了这种事。
He would walk in and say hello to the other four, and just ignore me like I wasn't there.
他会走进来，和另外四个人打招呼，只是无视我，好像我不在那儿一样。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共电台。